مرحبا بكم في هذه التغطيه المستمره
لتطورات في السودان نبدا بابرس العناوين
[موسيقى]
جهود اقليميه ودوليه لتمديد الهدنه في
السودان منظمه الايجاد تعرض مبادره على
طرفين نزاع لمواصله وقف اطلاق النار وبدء
التفاوض في جوبا والجيش السوداني يعلن
موافقه مبدئيه من البرهان ووزير خارجيه
جنوب السودان يقول ان الحوار المباشر بين
البرهان وحميتي غير ممكن في الوقت الراهن
[موسيقى]
في رابع هدنه منذ بدء المواجهات في
السودان اشتباكات في محيط القصر الجمهوري
ومقر القياده العامه في الخرطوم ومواجهات
في ام درمان والخرطوم بحري الجيش يستقدم
التعزيزات عسكريه الى الخرطوم وقوه الدعم
السريع ترسل تعزيزات من المناطق الغربيه
والجنوبيه الغربيه
منظمه الصحه العالميه تقول ان اكثر من 80%
من المشاه الصحيه في السودان باتت خارج
الخدمه المتحدثه الاقليميه للجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر تقول للجزيره ان توفير
الضمانات الامنيه لعمل الطواقم الطبيه
اولويه والامم المتحده تقول ان وكالتها
تستعد لموجه لجوء الى دول الجوار
اذا البدايه مع بيان القياده العامه للجيش
السوداني الذي اعلن موافقه عبد الفتاح
البرهان بشكل مبدئي على مبادره من منظمه
ايجاد تضمنت مقترحات لحل الازمه الحاليه
وبحسب بيان الجيش فان المقترحات تتضمن
تمديد الهدنه اثنتين وسبعين ساعه كما تشمل
مقترحات الاجهاد افاده ممثلين عن القوات
المسلحه والميليشيا المتمرده الى جبال
التفاوض بحسب وصف البيان
وكان وزير خارجيه جنوب السودان دينغ دو
قال للجزيره ان رئيس دوله جنوب السودان
سلفاكير تقدم باقتراح لطرفي الصراع من اجل
اجراء حوار سواء داخل السودان او خارجه
وان منظمه ايجاد تترقب ردود الاطراف مشيرا
الى ان الظرف الراهن لن يسمح بعقد لقاء
مباشر بين البرهان وحميتي
ان متوسط الخرطوم ورست الجزيره هيثم اويت
هيثم اطلعنا على سياق هذه المبادره من
ايجاد
طبعا هذه المبادره تاتي في اطار القلق
البالغ الذي تشعر به دول الايجات من
استمرار الصراع في السودان
واشتداده يعني توسعه وبالتالي هذا جاءت
هذه المبادره في محاوله لحقن الدماء وهي
مبادره تقدم بها رئيس دوله جنوب السودان
بالنيابه عن مجموعه دول الايغات التي
انخرطت في اجتماعات متواصله فيما بينها
طيله الفتره الماضيه هذه المبادره في
الجزء الاول منها هي يعني تحوي
البندي تمديد الفتره الهدنه حتى نهايه
ابريل الجاري وبالتالي لاتاحه الفرصه لوقف
اطلاق النار وتحسين الظروف الحياتيه للناس
جراء الحرب ايضا هذه المبادره يعني تاتي
في اطار انه تجمع الاطراف وان كان عن طريق
ممثلين طبعا الايجاد كانت كلفت رؤساء
والجنوب السودان وكينيا وجيبوتي للحضور
الى الخرطوم والجلوس مع طرفي الصراع من
اجل ايجاد صيغه لوقف هذه الحرب وفتح طاوله
حوار بين الطرفين ولكن عندما كان هذا
مستحيلا مع وجود الحرب القائمه الان وعدم
ايجاد وسيله للوصول الى الخرطوم بالنسبه
لتعطل الملاحه الجويه في مطار الخرطوم
استبدلت هذه الخطوه بخطوه ابتعاث ممثلين
لكل من الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع الى جبة
للتباحث والوضع الترتيبات الاوليه او
النقاط الاوليه
لتمهيد الارضيه لمفاوضات تكون بين
الجانبين تفضي الى يعني ايجاد حل لهذه
المشكله المبادره تقدم بها رئيس جنوب
السودان بخطاب مكتوب خطي لكل من رئيس مجلس
السياده قائد الجيش البرهان وقائد قوات
الدعم السريع
محمد حمدان دقلو حميتي
وينتظر ان يتم الرد عليها وما اذا كانت
سترسل هذه الوفود ممثلين لها في الى جوبا
لبدء التفاوض او ربما في في مرحله اولى
للموافقه على وقف اطلاق النار يعني جاءت
هدنه حقيقيه هذه المره تساهم في يعني
تحسين الاوضاع الميدانيه ووقفي القتال
وبالتالي تهيا الاجواء لاجراء اي حوار
مبدئي وهذا ما زلت تامله منظمه الايجات من
خلال بياناتها المتتاليه ودعواتها
المستمره لطرفي الصراع في السودان هيثم
اشاره وزير خارجيه جنوب السوداني لان
الظرف الراهن لا يسمح بلقاء البرهان
واحميتي كيف نفهمه
وربما الاشاره في هذه النقطه ان حتى الان
القتال محتدم عمليه ربما
مساله خروج ربما القائدين من من هذه من
ميدان المعركه الى جبهه ايضا ربما هناك
بعض المصاعب التي تصعب هذه الخطوه نحن حتى
الان لا يعلم احد اين يتواجد قائدي
المعركه بالتحديد وان كان هناك تصريحات
لهما بالكل يصرح بانه موجود في ميدان
المعركه او يدير العمل من داخل المكاتب
المؤسسات الرسميه ولكن ربما على الارض هذه
المساله بها بعض التعقيدات لانه القتال
يشتد في جميع المحاور التي بها هذه
المؤسسات الرسميه للدوله وبالتالي ربما في
ظل تعليق المجال الجوي ايضا لمطار الخرطوم
ربما من الصعوبه بمكان
الالتقاء او السفر في هذا التوقيت او ربما
الجو المشحون اصلا الان هذه المرحله لا
يسمح بالجلوس وجها لوجه للقائدين ما لم
تكون هناك يعني تمهيد لهذه الخطوه من قبل
المفاوضات الغير مباشره من خلال الممثلين
وربما عرض الاطروحات لكل طرف في مرحله
مبدئيه شروطه وما يستند عليه من مرحله
المفاوضات تمهيدا لتقديم ربما فرصه لايجاد
لتلعب دور الوساطه وعرضي ايضا يعني رؤيتها
للطرفين ومن ثم تمهيد للالتقاء شكرا لك
هيثم سنعود اليك طبعا في الساعات اللاحقه
امدادات الجيش السوداني تقابلها امدادات
اخرى لقوات الدعم السريع من المناطق
الغربيه والجنوبيه الغربيه شكل القتال
اليوم ورقعته على الخريطه السودانيه في
العرض التالي
12 يوما من الاشتباكات في السودان يتركز
القتال في العاصمه بمدنها الثلاث قصف
بالمدفعيه الثقيله في منطقه الفتحاب
جنوبيه ام درمان اشتباكات مسلحه شمال
الخرطوم بحري لكن الاشتباكات الانف تركزت
في مدينه الخرطوم وتحديدا محيط القصر
الجمهوري ومقر القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه يتبادل الطرف القتال الاتهامات
بجان خرق الهدنه يقول الجيش السوداني ان
الدعم السريع واصل محاولات الهجوم على مقر
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه في محيط
المطار بينما قالت قوه الدعم السريع ان
الجيش هاجما بالمدفعيه والطيران الحربي
مواقع تمركز الدعم السريع في القصر
الجمهوري في محيط العاصمه تتواصل
الامدادات العسكريه لكلا الطرفين تتوافد
تعزيزات الجيش قادمه من المناطق الشماليه
في العاصمه باتجاه الاحياء الجنوبيه في
الخرطوم بحري وام درمان يتواصل وامدادات
قوات الدعم السريع قادمه من المناطق
الغربيه والجنوبيه الغربيه من البلاد وتلك
مناطق تعتبر نقاط ارتكاز للدعم السريع كل
هذه الاشتباكات اسفرت وفق وزاره الصحه
السودانيه عن مقتل اكثر من 50012 سودانيه
وجرح الالاف بينما تتواصل عمليات اجلاء
الاجانب الى بلدانهم عبر مدينه بورتسودان
بمطارها ومينائها شرقيا البلاد
[موسيقى]
السيده الجميل الفاضل للكاتبه والمحلي
السياسيين من الخرطوم سيد جميل كيف ترون
مبادره ايجاد
جميل هل تسمعني
لا يبدو ان السيد جميل الفاضل لا يستطيع
سماعنا نتابع في التحركات الدوليه حيث قال
منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس
الامن القومي في البيت الابيض جون كربي ان
وقفه اطلاق النار الذي توسطت فيه الخارجيه
الامريكيه يبدو صامدا الى حد كبير رغم
التقارير عن اعمال عنف كربي اضافها في
تصريحات لقناه سي ان ان الاداره الامريكيه
ترغب في تمديد وقف اطلاق النار حتى يتم
ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه الى السودان
مؤكدا التواصل مع طرفي الصراع بهذا الصدد
واوضح كوربي ان بلاده تركز حاليا على
مساعده رعاياها على مغادره السودان
اذا نعود مره جديده للسيد الجميل الفاضل
الكاتب والمحل السياسي في الخرطوم هل
تسمعه لسيد الجميل
نعم نعم ما رايكم وكيف ترون مبادره ايجاد
نعم انا في تقديري ان
الايجاد قد نشطت لوقت مبكر في امكانيه
افاد ثلاثه من رؤساء المنطقه الى الخرطوم
لكن تعثرت جهود الايجاد بسبب صعوبه الوصول
الى الخرطوم الان هي تحاول ان تحرك هذه
الجهود باتجاه طلب هدنه اضافيه تمتد الى
نهايه الشهر
وتمت الاستجابه الاوليه لها
وبالتالي هذا يجعل ان الايقاد دخلت في
المزمار بشكل مباشر هناك ايضا الاستجابه
المعلنه حتى الان من جانب الجيش السوداني
هل لديك معلومات عن استجابه او او قبول من
قبل الدعم السريع لهذه المبادره
انا لا امتلك معلومات محدده لكن في تقديري
ان
القائد الدعم السريع ربما لا يعترض على
مبدا مبدا المبادره قد ظل يستجيب هو في
المبادرات التي طرحت من جهات مختلفه لكن
ربما يتعذر عليهم في الدعوه الاولى التي
اطلقت بضروره وصول القائدين الى جبه ربما
يتعذر عليهم
لارتباطاتهم
بالمواجهات العسكريه والاشتباك الذي يحدث
في الخرطوم واداره شؤون المعرفه وعوامل
الاخرى يمكن تتصل
بالاوضاع الامنيه ايضا كيفيه تامين وصوله
الى لكن في نهايه العمر يبدو ان ممثلين من
كلا الطرفين يمكن ان يذهب الى جوبا انا لا
امتلك معلومات من جهه الطرف الاخر وهل هو
اعطى الضوء الاخضر او الموافقه لكن
نحن نحاول ان نتواصل مع المتحدث باسم قوات
الدعم السريع لنعرف موقفها من هذه
المبادره في حال تمت فعلا وتم الاستجابه
لهذه المبادره وهي الهدف منها بحسب ايجاد
وقف دائم باطلاق النار ما حظوظها بتقديرك
جميل
الى الان انا يبدو لي ان هناك حاله من
الرهق قد اصابت الاطراف ويبدو ان كلا
الطرفين الان بحاجه الى مهله اطول وتوقف
لاطلاق النار حتى ترتيب
شانهما الداخلي كلا على حده وحتى يعيدها
تقييم الموقف
وفق ما جرى خلال
الايام الماضيه
اثني عشر يوم وبالتالي انا اتصور ان
الطرفين يمكن ان يفكران في ابتهال هذه
الفرصه لقبول هدنه اطول حتى يعيداء النظر
في المواقب خاصه وانا الاشارات التي صدرت
من الفريق اول عبد الفتاح البرهان في
المقابلات الصحفيه بان هذه وصف هذه الحرب
بانها حرب عباسيه والجنرال محمد حمدان
دقله التي وصف المنتصر في هذه الحرب بانه
خاسر اعتقد بعد مضيء اكثر من عشره ايام في
المواجهات ربما يصبح هناك نوع من الاستماع
لصوت العقل من كلا الطرفين وبعد الكوارث
والماسي الانسانيه الضخمه التي يتحملان
بجرها امام الشعب السوداني وامام العالم
انا في تقديري انهم بحاجه ايضا
لايقاف هذا النزيف الذي ظل مستمرا
وهما هما ايضا بحاجه
لمراجعه الاوضاع الداخليه لكلا القوتين
هذا السيد الجميل اذا سمحت لي رغم ما
تفضلت به ورغم هذه الجهود
تقارير المحليه تفيد بارسال طرفي النزاع
تعزيزات اضافيه الى الخرطوم تعزيزات
عسكريه طبعا الى الخرطوم ما دلاله هذا
هلا حتى المؤشر الذي يتعلق بارسال
باستخدام تعزيزات اضافيه سواء من اقليم
دارفور او من جنوب البلاد الحالي هذا يعني
ان ميزان القوه في الخرطوم لا زال بحاجه
الى قوات اضافيه ترجح كفه على حساب كفه
وهذا الوضع يعني ان الاوضاع غير مستقره
وهذا ما يقود الى حدوث اختراقات مستمره في
اي وقت في الاطلاق النار لان هناك محاولات
للاستفاده من من اي هدنه تعلن في تعزيز
المواقع وفي تبديل والتموضع للقوات في
مناطق اكثر استراتيجيه بالنسبه للقوات
الدعم السرقه
المناطق السكنيه التي توفر لها نوع من
الحمايه من الهجمات الجويه وبالنسبه
للقوات المسلحه لفك الطوق عن النقاط
الاستراتيجيه القصر والقياده العامه
والمطار وانا اعتقد كل الطرفين في
استراتيجيه له استراتيجيته الخاصه يحاول
ان يستفيد من فتره الهدنه في تعزيز تموضعه
في النقاط التي يرى بان بالضروره ان تقوم
بيده السيد الجميل كيف ترون خروج قيادات
للنظام السابق من السجن في هذا التوقيت
انا لا اتصور ان هذه العمليه حدثت من قبيل
السطوع ربما ان هناك سيناريو قد تم نسجه
بعنايه
والاستفاده من ظاهره
التحرير السجناء في اكثر من اربعه او خمسه
سجون بخلاف سجن كوبر وربما هذه الحوادث
التي وقعت في سجن الهدى او سجن سوبا او
سجن النساء او سجن في دارفور ربما هذه
الخطوات تمت لتهيئه الراي العام لتقبل
فكره انما حدث في سجن كوبر يندرج في سياق
ذات الاحداث التي وقعت في سجون شكرا ولذلك
هي خطوه ربما اتت في مناخ الحرب نعم شكرا
لك الجميل الفاضل الصحفي والمحلل السياسي
في الخرطوم ونبقى في الخرطوم وينضم الينا
عبر الهاتف السيد حافظ كبير الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي سيد حافظ ما دلاله موافقه
الجيش السوداني او اعلان الجيش السوداني
موافقه السيد البرهان على مبادره ايجاد
انا اعتقد ان هذا تطور كبير وايجابي
ومبادره تنصبوا في يعني اليهود الاقليميه
من اجل من اجل الوصول الى حل ونحن لدينا
تجارب كثيره وكذلك التجارب مع المنظمات
الاقليميه وهي تعلم جيدا طبيعه الصناعه
وطبيعه السودان وكذلك يتعلم يعني لديها
تجارب مماثله وبالتالي الدعم السريع ايضا
منذ اليوم الاول قال بانه يعمل من اجل
الاستعاده في العمليه السياسيه من اجل
التحول المدني لتحول الديمقراطي وهذا يعني
تماشى مع رؤيته التفاوض والحوار للوصول
الى هذه الدوله وبالتالي الايجابيه جزء من
الاليه الثلاثيه
اطلع على تفاصيل الخلاف ومطلعه على
النقاشات التي جرت في العمليه السياسيه
بالتالي هي اكثر من غيرها يعني مؤخره
كبيره الى يعني التوسط وقياده هذه العمليه
وصولا الى الحل اعتقد ان هناك جهود كبيره
خلال الايام الماضيه خلال الهدنه
وكذلك الدوري الامريكيه وبريطانيا المملكه
العربيه السعوديه او سرعه
نفهم منك ان الدعم السريع يتجه نحو
الموافقه ايضا على هذه المبادره
لم يرفض اي حل عبر الحوار انه يسترد
بالطبع بعض الاشتراطات للدخول في عمليه
كهذه هو يرى بان هناك تيارا كبيرا من
النظام الباقي يسيطر على الجيش وهو يرى
بضروره ابعاده التيار
والتفاوض مع الجيش الجيش الذي لديه مصلحه
في
في وحده الجيش وكذلك في استقلاله من
التدخل السياسي الجيش يعاني كثيرا من
تضارب
سياسيه وكذلك مصلحته كمصحه وطنيه وهناك
يعني عدم وضوح في الرؤيه حتى الان بين بين
المصلحه الوطنيه وبين المصلحه الضيقه
الحزبيه التي تظهر بشكل واضح في رفض
السلام ورفض التفاوض تمام
ا والتياح
لحفل الذي تتورم منه البلاد بصوره كبيره
كما نشاهد الان وبالتالي شكرا نتوقع
اتجاهات داخل الجيش حاليا ترفض هذه الهدنه
وترفض التفاوض لكن في الغالب تضمن الامور
نحو التفاوض والحل السلمي خفض كبير الكاتب
والمحلي السياسي في الخرطوم شكرا لك
ونشرك معنا السيد عبد الباسط ادريس الصحفي
والمحلل السياسي السيد عبد الباسط طبعا
السيد البرهان اعلن موافقته المبدئيه على
هذه المبادره من ايجاد كيف تفهم هذه
الموافقه من السيد البرهان
يبدو ان على العقائد الجيش الفريق والعبد
الفتاح البرهان يستخدم
ادبلوماسيه الهاتف المشغول لانه يدرك
صعوبه صدور قرار دولي سواء كان من مجلس
الامن او من بعض المنظمات في هذا التوقيت
في ظل الانقسام الدولي تجاه ما يحدث في
السودان وتوصيف ما يجري في البلاد
وبالتالي هو يريد ان يقول انه يرغب في حل
ولكنه عبر البيت الافريقي عبر المنظمه
الايجاد ومعروف انه هو الان يراس
بصفته رئيس مجلس السياده الدوره الحاليه
للايجاد ودول الايجاد تحتفظ بعلاقات
جيده مع السودان مسلكينيا وجنوب السودان
ويوغندا واثيوبيا وجبوتي وبالتالي في هذا
التوقيت هو رحب بهذه
المبادره وفي السياق تردد ايضا انه دفع
قبل ايام
بوكيل وزاره الخارجيه السفير دفع الله
الحاج علي ليكون مبعوثا خاصا له لدول
الايجاد والدول الافريقيه لشرح ما يجري في
السودان واعتقد ان هذا الرجل يعني يحتفظ
بقدري كبير جدا من العلاقات الخارجيه
ولديه رصيد وافر من التجارب عملها في وقت
سابق في مبعوث مندوب للسودان لدى الامم
المتحده
سيد عبد الباسط في حال وافق الدعم السريع
ايضا عليها
اعتقد ان هذه المبادره الرهينه
بالاشتراطات التي سيتقدم بها الطرف الذي
يسيطر الان على الاوضاع على الارض وفي
تقديري ان جيش ربما يرى انه الان العمليات
العسكريه في البلاد تنظيم لصالحه هنالك
اكثر من 15 ولايه خاليه من التمرد تماما
التمرد الان منحصر فيه العاصمه الخرطوم
وما تبقى منه محاصر ويتحرك هنا وهناك
ويحتلوا هنا ويخلو موقع اخر وبالتالي
الجيش
يرى انه يمتلك السند الشعبي ويمتلك
العقيده ويمتلك
السلاح الاستراتيجي الحاسم والعلاقات
الخارجيه والكادر البشري الذي يمكنه من
تحقيق
انتصار كبير بعد ان وجه ضرب قاصمه لقوات
الدعم السريع بفصل قيادتها ومن يغفونها
وماذا عن شروط الجيش السيد عبد الباسط
القتاليه عن شروط الجيش
هل يمكن شروط الجيش ايضا ان تكون محبطه
لهذه المبادره
نعم
نعم ربما يعني الجيش يتمسك في هذا بالدمج
ما تبغى من هذه القوات فورا داخل القوات
المسلحه
والعمليات التي تجري الان في الخرطوم من
كروه فرو هو يحاصر هذه القوات حتى يدفعها
في هذا الاتجاه اتجاه ان تستسلم
وتندمج في القوات المسلحه لان الجيش مات
وغير الجيش نفسه ممهد لهذه الخطوه
بفصل واضح حرس الحدود من قوات الدعم
السريع واصبحت قوه تتبع للقوات البريه بعد
صدور قرار تاني من رئيس اركان الجيش
وبالتالي اعتقد ان الامور ستمضي في هذا
الاتجاه اتجاه شرط دمج ما تبقى من قوات
الدعم السريع دون اي تاخير او ابطاء ومن
ثم
النظر في امكانيه استئناف المسار السياسي
الذي يمكن ان يعيد الاستقرار ولكن الدمج
السريع للدعم السريع سيد عبد الباسط هو
كان السبب الاساسي في انطلاق هذه
المواجهات واشتعال
النزاع في في الشارع لماذا سيوافق الان
الدعم السريع على هذا الشرط من الجيش
نعم الان
توازن القوه ليس في صالح الدعم السريع هو
ليس جدا للجيش ولا يمتلك امكانيات الجيش
وقد جرت مفاوضات سابقه في لجان مشتركه بين
ممثل الدعم السريع والقوات المسلحه للتوصل
الى غير زمني للدمج وكان المقترح الذي
تقدم به المكون
العسكري او ممثلين اللجنه العسكريه من
جانب الجيش في ان تكون عامين الى ثلاثه
اعوام ولكن الدعم السريع رفض هذا تماما
وغال انه لابد ان تاتي حكومه منتخبه حسب
ما علمت بحسب الانباء التي ترددت حتى تنظر
في موضوع هذه القوات وفي هذه المساحات
دخلت
الاليه الثلاثيه عبر من رئيس بعثه الامم
المتحده فوق الكرم وغال انه من الممكن ان
تتم هذه العمليه خلال عشر اعوام وبالتالي
الجيش حمل هذا الدعم السريع حملا على ان
الان تدمج قوات لانه لا خيار له بعد ان
صنفت هذه القوات او جزء من هذه القوات
بانها متمرده لا سبيل امامها سوى
الاستسلامات في الجيش او سيتعامل معها
الجيش والغ ما يقول غادته
برز في الساعات الماضيه خروج قيادات
للنظام السابق من السجن هل تتوقع انعكاسات
لتواجد هذه القيادات خارج السجن على
الانقسام الحاصل الان في السودان وعلى
المشهد برمته باقتضاب لو سمحت
من ناحيه من الناحيه السياسيه هم اصلا ولا
خضعوا لمحاكمات يقولون بان هذه المحاكمات
محاكمات السياسيه بعد اكثر من ثلاثين عاما
يحاكمون على انقلاب تاسست عليه عمليه
سياسيه ودستوريه متراكمه وتاسست على
اتفاقيات سلام وبالتالي هم يرون ان هذه
المحاكمه ابتداء هي محاكمه سياسيه الان مع
خروج قيادات النظام ربما يتيح هامش
للتواصل المدني المدني بين القوى السياسيه
للوصول الى نوع من الصبغه او الحوار
السياسي الذي من شانه ان يقود البلاد الى
مصالحه وطنيه شامله لانه ليس من مصلحه
القوى المدنيه الان التناحر والتنافر
الصحفي والمحلل السياسي عبد الباسط ادريس
في الخرطوم شكرا لك
حول هذه القضيه قضيه سجون اذا اتهمت وزاره
الداخليه قوه الدعم السريع بالمسؤوليه عن
الاضطرابات والجرائم الخطيره في البلاد
ومنها اقتحام عدد من السجون واطلاق سراح
من سمتهم عتات المجرمين
من قوات الدعم السريع خروج قياديين في
نظام عمر البشير من السجون ممارسه تضليليه
مكشوفه تهدف الى استعاده نظام السابق
تم اخلائهم كلهم لا تستغرب انها الفوضى
فتوقع اي شيء تقدر وسائل اعلام غربيه عدد
السجناء الفارين من السجون السودانيه منذ
بدء النزاع المسلح بنحو 20000
المساله تاخذ ابعادا مختلفه مع اتضاح ان
بينما الفارو رموزا في النظام السابق
ليس الرئيس المعزول عمر البشير بينهم
فالجيش السوداني اكد رسميا انه لا يزال في
مستشفى علياء التابع للقوات المسلحه لكن
لمصلحه من هروب او تهريب بعض من ابرز
مساعديه والمسؤولين في نظامه
باسرع مما يمكن لاحد ان يتوقع يرسم
القيادي في حزب المؤتمر الوطني المنحل
والمطلوب لمحكمه الجنايات الدوليه احمد
هارون خريطه طريقه ومن معه
وقوفنا معكم في خندق الوطن لمنع اختطافه
لصالح مشروع اسري مدعوم دوليا واقليميا
علم الجهه التي يقصد بانه يقصدها لكن قوات
الدعم السريع ترى في خروج قيادات في نظام
عمر البشير من السجون ما تصفها بممارسه
تظليليه مكشوفه تهدف الى استعاده النظام
السابق
وتلك رؤيه تشاطرها قوى الحريه والتغيير
المجلس المركزي
فماذا عن الجيش الذي يدعو هارون الشعب
السوداني للالتفاف حوله
نقى الجيش السوداني بنفسه عن كل تلك
تطورات اذ ان سلطه الاشراف على سجون
البلاد كما اوضح تقع خارج نطاق اختصاصه
لكنه وزاره الداخليه السودانيه لا تتردد
في اتهام قوات الدعم السريع بالمسؤوليه عن
الاضطرابات والجرائم الخطيره التي
ارتكبتها في حق البلاد كما قالت ومنها
اقتحام عدد من سجون البلاد واطلاق سراح من
سمتهم عوتات المجرمين
لا يجد مراقبون بددا من مقاربه مساله
الخروج الكثيف والمباغت من السجون من
زاويه سياسيه والا لما تبادل الجيش والدعم
السريع الاتهامات بتهيئه الظروف لما حدث
في كوبر وغيره من السجون فكل طرف يحمل
الاخر مسؤوليه محاوله تجهيير الفوضى
لمصلحه اجندته السياسيه
والقراءات السياسيه لعوده قيادات من حزب
المؤتمر الوطني المنحل الى واجهه الاحداث
قد تتباين لكنها جميعا تضع المساله في
السياق العام للتطورات اللاهبه في البلد
وتتوقع ان هذا المعطى الجديد سيعمق حاله
الاستقطاب الحاده في اصلها ويزيد لا ريب
من تعقيد المشهد السوداني باكمله
وفي الارتدادات الانسانيه للمواجهات توقع
مدير منظمه الصحه العالميه تدرس ادهنوم
كابريسوس مزيدا من الوفيات في السودان
جراء نقص الخدمات واشار المسؤول الامامي
لنا 60% من المشاه الصحيه في الخرطوم
مغلقه وان 16% فقط من هذه المرافق الصحيه
هي التي تقدم خدماتها للسودانيين
من القاهره ريتشارد برانن مدير برنامج
الطوارئ بالمكتب الاقليمي لمنظمه الصحه
العالميه سيد ريتشارد ما انعكاسات نقص
الخدمات الصحيه والطبيه على السودانيه
[موسيقى]
ان الوضع الصحي في السودان حاليا هو على
شفا كارثه حقيقيه الان في الخرطوم لوحدها
نقدر انه تقريبا اكثر من 60% من
المستشفيات والعيادات خارج نطاق الخدمه
وهذا يعتبروا كارثه للالاف من المرضى
الذين
اصيبوا نتيجه
النزاع وهذه كارثه ايضا للنساء التي يريدن
ان يردنا في بيئه امنه وخاصه تلك اللواتي
يواجهني صعوبات في الانجاب وهذا ايضا
يعتبر كارثه
للجميع اذا فهذا الصراع الذي هو في ازدياد
في سوءه يضع النظام الرعايه الصحيه في وضع
مهلهل
يصبح من الصعب اكثر واكثر كل يوم تقديم
الخدمات التي يحتاجها الناس والشعب في
السودان ما خطه الطوارئ وامكانيه تنفيذها
في ظل التقييم الرهن لكم سيد ريتشارد
هذا سؤال وجيه جدا انه من الصعب للغايه ان
يكون هناك خطه واضحه للتجاوب مع هذا الوضع
الغير امن والفوضوي جدا ولعلكم تتخيلون
فان الكثير من الناس فروا من القتال وكان
علينا اجلاء الموظفين واعاده مركزتهم بسبب
انعدام الامن
وموظفون كما هم المدنيون هم ايضا في
وضع يواجهون فيه الاخطار الهائله اليوم تم
سلب اثنين من موظفين وما يملكون وسته
عربات لدينا سرقت وبالتالي فنحن نقوم
بافضل ما بوشعينا لكي نقدمه المواد
والمعدات للمستشفيات في الخرطوم وقدمنا
الوقود ايضا لبعض المستشفيات الرئيسيه
لدينا المزيد من
المواد والموارد وادوات الجراحه في بورت
سودان
وفي
دبي ونحن ننتظر الاتيان بهذه الموارد الى
البلاد وان نوزعها باسرع وقت ممكن من
مكتبنا اللوجستي في دبي ولكن جهودنا تعاق
بسبب الوضع الامني ولذلك فنحن مازلنا نعمل
لكي نقدم افضل ادوات التوزيع في بور وفي
الخرطوم وفي الاماكن الاخرى ايضا نعمل
ايضا مع وزاره الصحه
لرصد الحاجات الكبيره ولوضع الاولويات
اللازمه المتعلقه بتوزيع المواد ولكن
الوضع صعب للغايه بسبب انعدام الامن
والوضع الفوضوي جدا بالنسبه لكم كمدير
برنامج طوارئ هل فرار
السودانيين من الخرطوم واللجوء الى مناطق
اخرى هو الحل الانسب
يجب ان نضع انفسنا في موقف الناس على
الارض فالمسؤوليتهم الاولويه هي حمايه
عائلاتهم والانتقال الى اماكن امنه وهذا
ما يفعله اي شخص منا في ظل ظروف كهذه حسب
اعتقادي لذلك راينا الالاف من الناس الان
يعبرون الحدود الى تشاد والان بشكل متزايد
الى مصر وحتى في هذه البلدان نحن كمنظمه
الصحه العالميه نعمل مع وزارات الصحه
ونعمل ايضا مع شركائنا في
الامم المتحده مثل المفوضيه شامله لشؤون
اللاجئين لضمان ان الناس الذين مروا
بتجارب مروعه وهم مرهقون والكثير منهم
مرضى ذلك لنضمن ان حاجاتهم يتم تقييمها
بشكل سليم ومعالجتها اذا فهذه الازمه الان
هي
نواجهها السودان داخل مصر وداخل تشاد
وبالفعل حتى في دوله جنوب السودان الان
اذا فهذا يعتبر ازمه اقليميه وذلك لتدفق
اللاجئين من السودان ونحن بحاجه الى
المزيد من الموارد والمعدات وعلينا ان
نزيد من مستوى المعدات لكي نفي بحاجات من
تضرروا بهذه الازمه شكرا لك مدير برنامج
الطوارئ بالمكتب الصحه العالميه
انهيار نظام الصحي خطر يهدد السودان الان
بسبب المواجهات المسلحه تقول منظمه الصحه
العالميه ان 61% من المرافق الصحيه في
الخرطوم اغلقت وان 16% فقط منها تعمل بشكل
طبيعي
منذ اليوم الاول اندلاع المواجهات ركزت في
وسط المدينه حيث توجد اغلب المرافق الصحيه
تقول نقابه الاطباء السودانيين ان ثلاثه
ارباع المستشفيات في مناطق الاشتباكات
بالعاصمه السودانيه توقفت عن العمل يجد
العاملون في المؤسسات الطبيه انفسهم امام
معركتين الان استقبال واسعاف المصابين
ومواجهتها هجمات مسلحه حسب نقابه الاطباء
قصف مسلحون ثلاثه عشر مستشفى في مختلف
انحاء البلاد وتم افراغ 19 مستشفى اخر اما
منظمه الصحه العالميه فاحصى الثمانيه قتلى
على الاقل فيها هجمات مباشره على مستشفيات
يعاني السودانيون للحصول على ادويه خصوصا
للامراض المزمنه وتحذر منظمه يونيسيف من
انما قيمته 40 مليون دولار من اللقاحات
ومن ماده الانسولين مهدده بالتلف في
مخازنها بسبب انقطاعات التيار الكهرب ائي
وتوقف امدادات البنزين كل هذه تطورات دفعت
منظمه الصحه العالميه الى توقع مزيد من
الوفيات جراء نقص الخدمات ليتحول هذا
النقص ايضا الى سلاح فتاك يفرض هذا الوضع
تحديات جديده على نظام صحي هش ساهمت عوامل
عده في تفككه منها الاضطرابات السياسيه
والعسكريه وضعف الموارد وهجره الادمغه
حسب ارقام منظمه الصحه العالميه فان اكثر
من عشره ملايين سوداني في حاجه لمساعدات
طبيه
وتشير الاحصائيات الى ان السودان خسر نحو
60% من اطباءه بسبب الهجره التي تسببت
فيها الاضطرابات السياسيه وما رافقها من
ازمات اقتصاديه امام هذا الوضع يبدو
احتمال استمرار المواجهات العسكريه
كالكابوس بالنسبه الى السودانيين لان
نظامهم الصحي المنهك لن يتحمل تبعات حرب
مفتوحه على المجهول
نقص الخدمات والمعارك يدفعني نحو وموجات
نزوح ولجوء متزايده حيث حذرت الامم
المتحده من موجه رجوء نحو الجوار السوداني
ومع تضاؤل فرص عمل المنظمات قالت منظمه
الصليب الاحمر ان العمل على توفير
الضمانات الامنيه لافرادها اولويه لاكمال
انشطتها في الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
السيده لتيتيا كورتوا المراقبه الدائمه
للجنه الدوليه للسالب الاحمر لدى الامم
المتحده ورئيسه بعثه اللجنه في نيويورك
تنضم الينا ما الظروف التي ترافق خروج
السودانيين الى اماكن اكثر امنا سواء داخل
السودان او خارجها
شكرا جزيلا للاستضافه الوضع صعب جدا
والايام العاشره الاخيره من القتال
المحتدم في الاماكن المزدحمه بالناس
المدنيين كان لها اثر عظيم على الناس
الناس اما انهم علقوا في منازلهم وغير
قادرين على الوصول الى الغذاء ومياه الشرب
والرعايه الصحيه
وايضا الدمار بسبب القصف الشديد ايضا عقد
سبيلهم للوصول الى هذه الاماكن
كالمستشفيات وما الى ذلك المستشفيات تاثرت
قدرتها على التقديم العلاج بسبب انعدام
المياه وانعدام القدرات والاطباء لم
يعودوا يذهبون الى هذه المستشفيات لكي
يقدموا الخدمات الاساسيه للشعب ولكن الناس
ايضا يشعرون بالذهول والرعب والخوف بسبب
المعارك التي تجري حتى على مستوى الشوارع
ولذلك الناس يشعرون بانهم في حاله خطره
ويحاولون ان يصلوا الى الخدمات الاساسيه
بينما يتم الان تنفيذ
الهدنه وذلك لكي يهتموا بانفسهم وعائلاتهم
ويصلوا الى الاماكن التي فيها
البضائع او الخدمات الاساسيه او الغذاء او
المياه او العلاج وما الامكانيات المتاحه
للمخيمات او اماكن لجوء السودانيين او
نزوحهم الى داخل السودان ما الذي يؤمن لهم
هناك
سودان
السودان لديه الان وضع انساني معقد حتى
قبل اندلاع العنف ثلاثه ملايين شخص الان
في دارفور شردوا
في اماكن اخرى في البلاد ايضا وايضا مليون
شخص كانوا يسعون للجوء الى السودان من دول
مجاوره بسبب العنف في تلك البلدان اذا
فهناك اناس هم الان في وضع صعب جدا وهش
للغايه هم ايضا
يواجهون عبئا اضافيا
لانه كان عليهم ان ينتقلوا ويفر من اماكن
التوتر والصراع التي هي تندلع ليس فقط في
الخرطوم ولكن فيها جاء اخرى من البلاد
والناس ذهبوا لللجوء الى اي مكان عن طريق
العبور عبر الحدود او الانتقال خارج
الخرطوم الى
اماكن اخرى في السودان بطريقه سريعه جدا
بسبب كثافه المعارك هل استطعتم صيدله من
الاستفاده من ساعات الهدن او وقفه اطلاق
النار
وان كانت نسبيه في مناطق معينه
ساعيد السؤال هل تمكنتم كلجنه الدوليه
الصليب الاحمر لايصال المساعدات
استفاده من ساعات وقف اطلاق النار او
الهدن التي كانت نسبيه
اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
وزملائها ومن يعملون معها يحاولون العمل
على قدم وساق وهم ككل الموظفين الانسانيين
يحاولون ان
يذهبوا ان يكونوا مع الناس في ملاجئهم وفي
الايام الاولى لم يستطيعوا التجاوب ولكن
في الوقت ذاته كنا نحاول القيامه
بالتواصل باقصى قدر ممكن زودنا مستشفيين
بمعدات طبيه في
دارفور ونامل للهدنه ان تساعدنا على تقييم
الحاجات ووضع الاولويات لدعم المستشفيات
وذلك لضمان ان المواد الاساسيه يتم
توزيعها الى هذه المستشفيات وايضا لكي
تقوم المستشفيات بوظائفها وخاصه فيما
يتعلق بعلاج الجرحى لكي يكون هناك التجاوب
مع الحالات الطارئه ولكن الوضع كان صعبا
جدا على فرقنا فيما يتعلق بالتحرك وايضا
قمنا بالعمل مع الاطراف للسماح لنا
باعطائنا
الانسانيه لكي نتحرك ونقدم الاستجابه
الضروريه اذا فنحن نقوم بزياده جهودنا
استنادا الى المعلومات التي تصلنا لكي
نعمل فور ان تصلنا الضمانات الامنيه لكي
نقدم الخدمات الضروريه والطارئه للناس في
حال استمرت هذه المعارك وهذا النزاع ما هي
الخطه الموضوعه على المدى القصير
صيدلاتيتيا
خطتنا على المدى القصير هي ان نقوم وفوريا
بمعالجه احتياجات المستشفيات وكما اشار
زميلي من منظمه الصحه العالميه الكثير من
المستشفيات غير قادره على تلبيه الحاجات
فالحاجات هي اكثر من سعتهم وقدراتهم اذا
يجب ان نساعدهم فورا ايضا الاولويه الاخرى
هي تقديم
واستعاده منشات المياه والكهرباء
ونقل فرق الصيانه لكي يقوموا باصلاح هذه
الخدمات الاساسيه التي تسمح للمستشفيات
بالقيام بوظائفها نحن قلقون ايضا بشان
العائلات التي فصلت افراد عن بعضها البعض
بسبب العنف المحتدم والكثيرون فقدوا
احبتهم ولم يدروا يعودوا يعرفون اين هم
لذلك يجب ان نعيد لم شملهم فالتواصل بين
العائلات يعتبر احدى اولوياتنا
المراقبه الدائمه للجنه الدوليه للصليب
الاحمر لدى الامم المتحده
معاناه كبيره تواجه المدنين في السودان
فقد شهدت شوارع الخرطوم بحري دمارا كبيرا
عقب المواجهات التي دارت بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع وقد حصلت
الجزيره على صور خاصه تكشف جانبا من
الدمار الذي لحق ببعض المباني والاحياء
كما تظهر صور انتشار مقذوفات غير متفجره
في الشوارع مما يشكل خطرا على المدنيين
نحن هنا في ضاحيه شمبات شمال الخرطوم
بحريه هذه المنطقه وتحديدا من امام السوق
المركز الخضر والفاكهه كانت مسرح لمعركه
عنيفه جدا بين القوات المسلحه وقوات الدعم
السريعه السبت الماضي هذه الاثار اثار
المعركه تبدو جليه من حيث المكان هذه
شاحنه كانت تحمل ذخائر
لمدفعيه ثقيله انفجرت بفعل الاشتباك
تناصرت شظايا الذخائر التي تفجرت في محيط
كل المنطقه
الخطر في الامر ان غالبيه هذه الزخائر لم
تنفجر بعد مما يشكل خطر على الماره خاصه
وان حركه السير اخذت في النشاط فضلا عن
الباعه الباعه والمستهلكين بدوي يتوافدون
الى منطقه المجاوره لهذا المكان لو تمكنتم
ستجدون العديد من الزخائف في هذه المنطقه
متناثره في في المكان حيث توجد زخائر
متفجره متناثره هناك
ذلك المكان لو اخذتها الكاميرا لكم ستكون
واضحه هذه الزخاير يمكن ان تنفجر في اي
لحظه بفعل درجات الحراره المرتفعه هذه
الايام فضلا عن اي حركه
في هذه الزغاير عن طريقه التدحرج او عن
طريق ان تضعها اقدام الماره او
اطارات السيارات التي تعبر من هذا المكان
يبدو واضحا ان هذه
المتفجرات تحتاج الى
مختصين حتى يمكن
التقاطها من هنا
وبحيث يمكن ازاله الخطر من هذا المكان
يبدو واضحا اثار الانفجار في البنايات
بحيث بسبب
الانفجارات التي
تسببت فيها هذه الذخائر مما الحقت اضرار
بالغه بالبنيات
هذه البنايات هي
السكن لضباط الشرطه ايضا يبدو واضحا وجليا
الاضرار التي لحقت بواجهه السوق المركزي
وهو سوق رئيسي في المنطقه هذه المعركه
تبدو اثارها هجريه
وتعد من ابرز
المعارك واعنفها في هذه المنطقه
يبدو الوضع هنا يحتاج الى تدخل السلطات
بشكل عاجل حتى يمكن التقاط وتفكيك هذه
المتفجرات والذخائر التي تبدو متنازله
بشكل عشوائي في ظل استمرار حركه السير في
هذا المكان الذي شهد في صول معركه حاميه
بين القوتين المتحاربتين منذ الخامس عشر
من هذا الشهر
الحديث اكثر عن افاق هذه الازمه وسبل الحل
ينضم الينا من لندن السيد ويليام باتيه
السفير البريطاني السابق لدى السودان
استفيد باتي ما دلاله بروز وتقدم مبادره
الايجاد في هذا التوقيت
جزء من الجهود الدوليه التي تتم مع الامم
المتحده والايجاد والاتحاد الافريقي وذلك
بغيه الاتيان
بخدمه اكثر استدامه والبدء في المفاوضات
لكي يكون هناك عمليه انتقاليه لحكم مدني
وعمليه سلميه يتم والاتيان بها
والدول مثل الولايات المتحده والمملكه
المتحده هو دول اخرى يدعون الاطراف
المتناحره في السودان لانهاء الصراع وذلك
لاسباب انسانيه
لانه اذا حاول اي معسكر الفوز بطريقه
عسكريه فهذا سوف يؤدي الى تدمير البلاد
وكيف
تتابع
الرباعيه هذا المسار هذا المسار السياسي
التفاوضي اذا صح التعبير
لها تاريخ طويل في العمل في السودان عندما
كنت سفيرا هناك الايجاد كانت لاعبا اساسيا
في انهاء الحرب الاهليه في السودان والتي
ادت الى اتفاقيه السلام الشامله وبالنهايه
الى استقلال جمهوريه جنوب السودان اذا
فالايجاد لديها تاريخ
بانها وسيط ناجح في جهود السلام في
السودان وهم يحضرون بالدعم من المجتمع
الدولي
والذين هم كلهم يخشون بان الوضع في
السودان يمكن ان يزعزع الاستقرار في دول
اخرى في المنطقه والتي بعضها اصلا تعاني
من الصراعات هي نفسها بالتالي محظوظ نجاح
هذه المبادره من الايجاد لوقف دائم لاطلاق
النار بتقديرك
يجب ان ننتظر كي نرى الى الان
الطرفان
يقاومان الجهود الدوليه للاتيان بوقف دائم
لاطلاق النار وكلاهما يعتقد بانه يمكن ان
له ان يفوز عسكريا وينتصر ولذلك ما زال
مستمران في القتال هناك حاجه لحل وسط
الشعب السوداني بحاجه الى وقف لهذا القتال
والدوله في حاله انهيار ليس هناك كهرباء
ولا طعام
والمساعدات الانسانيه الدوليه لا تدخل الى
السودان ما لم يستمع الطرفان للايجاد ودول
اخرى تحاول تثبيت وقفا اطلاق النار ستحل
كارثه كبيره في السودان هل تعتقد بان
الرباعيه والمجتمع الدولي الان
سيكتفي بمواكبه ودعم مبادره ايجاد طالما
انها الاكثر قبولا لدى الاطراف السودانيين
امانه سيتابع في في مساره محاولا ايجاد
ايضا وقف اطلاق نار بين طرفي الصراع
ان الرباعيه سوف تدعم اي مبادره يبدو
بانها ناجحه سواء كانت من الاتحاد
الافريقي او الامم المتحده او الايجاد
وانا اعلم انهم هم ايضا يحاولون التواصل
مع الطرفين لكي يقوم ما
بتمديد الهدنه
وام سوف
يدعمون الايجاد وسوف يقومون بجهودهم
الخاصه بهم لدعم كل الاطراف وذلك للتوصل
الى اتفاقيه ما شكرا لك السفير ويليام
السفير البريطاني السابق في السودان
اتابع مع اخبارنا الاخرى حيث كشفت رئاسه
الاوكرانيه عن صفقه تبادل جريده للاسرى مع
الجانب الروسي وقلت انها استعادت بموجبها
44 جنديا اوكرانيا اضافه الى مدنيين واكدت
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه ان معظم المفرج عنهم
سبق ان قاتلوا في خرسون وماريوبل ومناطق
اخرى شرقيه البلاد
اعلنت حركه النهضه في تونس تولي القيادي
في الحركه منذر الونيسي تسير شؤونها في
غياب رئيسها راشد الغنوشي المعتقل في
السجن وقالت الحركه في بيان ان لونيسي
سيتولى المنصب الى حين زوال الاسباب
واجددت الدعوه الى اطلاق سراح الغنوشي
وبقيه النشطاء السياسيين واكدت الحركه
التزامها بمواصله مشاركتها في اطار جبهه
الخلاص الوطني والسعي من اجل استعاده
المسار الديمقراطي في البلاد
وتقدم عدد من اهالي المعتقلين السياسيين
في تونس بطلب الى الاتحاد الاوروبي في
بروكسيل لفرض عقوبات على الرئيس التونسي
قيس سعيد ومسؤولين اخرين بسبب الانتهاكات
الجسيمه والمستمره لحقوق الانسان على حد
وصفهم وقال محامي المعتقلين في تونس ان
القائمه شبلت وزراء داخليه سابقين ووزراء
العدل والدفاع في تونس واشار المحامي لانه
قدم الطلب وفقا لنظام العقوبات العالمي
لحقوق الانسان التابع للاتحاد الاوروبي
شارك فلسطينيون من داخل الخط الاخضر في
مسيره العوده التي تقام على اراضي قريه
اللجون المهجر اهلها جنوب حيفا ورفع
المشاركون خلال المسيره شعارات تؤكد على
تمسكهم بحق العوده وبهويتهم الفلسطينيه
ورفض التوطين
اعلنت السلطات المحليه في بلده القربوللي
شرق العاصمه الليبيه طرابلس انتشال عشري
يثث للاجئين قباله شواطئ البلده امس
الثلاثاء واكد مصدر في حرس السواحل الليبي
للجزيره انقاذ 84 لاجئا كانوا على متن
قارب مطاطين اثناء توجههم الى جنوب اوروبا
انطلاقا من سواحل شرقي طرابلس
اعلنت السلطات الايرانيه مقتل عضو في مجلس
خبراء القياده عباس علي سليماني لدى تعرضه
لاطلاق نار اثناء وجوده في احد مصارف
مدينه
بوبلاسار بمحافظه مازندران شماليه البلاد
واظهر مقطع فيديو ما قيل انها لحظه مقتل
سليماني واعتقال منفذ الهجوم ودعى الرئيس
الايراني ابراهيم رئيس قوات الامن الى
التعرف بشكل عاجل على اسباب الحادثه
ودوافع منفذ العمليه
التغطيه مستمره القاكم على راس السحابقوا
معنا